the FBI is facing new and sharper
criticism this morning after the agency
admitted it mishandled a tip about the
suspect in this week's shooting massacre
at a Florida high school Florida
Governor Rick Scott is leading that
criticism calling on FBI director
Christopher ray to resign Manuel
Bojorquez is in parkland Florida where
grieving families are searching for
answers man well good morning good
morning at a news conference yesterday
the FBI apologized for any additional
pain the revelation of a ms tip may
cause the families of the 17 people who
were murdered here at Stoneman Douglas
High School this community wants to know
why a call to a tip line providing
information about the suspect Nicholas
Cruz was not investigated the caller
expressed concern that Cruz could attack
a school the agency was already facing
criticism for not being able to trace
the origin of a youtube comment posted
by a user named Nicholas Cruz that said
I'm going to be a professional school
shooter the President and First Lady
arrived here last night president Trump
praised
first responders and visited with
doctors and shooting victims here in
Broward County while Nicholas Cruz faces
17 counts of premeditated murder his
defense attorneys are reportedly
planning to offer a guilty plea to avoid
the possibility of a death sentence
going forward no student will ever step
foot inside the building behind me where
the shooting happened
school officials say it will eventually
be torn down a memorial likely taking
its place
Anthony Manuel Bojorquez in parkland
Florida thanks